hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast I cannot say that I have the
great pleasure of sitting with ephrat
fingon this morning because it is under
rather terrible circumstances but I am
honored to be speaking with her she is a
independent journalist in Israel and as
I was watching events unfold in the
aftermath of the attacks on October 7th
I
spotted her evaluation of the events and
my blood ran cold because suspicions
that I could not quite shake that
something about the story couldn't
possibly be what it appeared were
reflected very clearly in her analysis
and what's more she has a special
position from which to evaluate the
conflict having not only served in the
IDF but served on the Gaza border so she
is in possession of knowledge about how
things normally function there and
therefore her sense that something was
quite wrong on the morning of October
7th uh struck me as an important piece
of information for the world to
understand so welcome ifra thank you for
having me Brett it's a honor um I'm I'm
I'm truly glad to be uh talking with you
I should also tell our audience that I
have just discovered that we have
actually met already which I am
embarrassed to say that I did not
remember but you and I met at a
conference in bath
England um that was uh put on to gather
coid dissidents and so it turns out that
we have a a number of different uh
threads that we are um seeing in common
and perhaps we will get to that coid
thread later in the
discussion but let us start um by having
you realize um my audience isn't
inherently American but most of them are
not expert in the situation in the
Middle East surrounding the tensions
between Israel and its neighbors and
could probably use a lot of basic
information on who the players even are
and how they end up in the situation
they end up in before we get to the
attacks that occur on the seven so can
you just tell us what Gaza is what Hamas
is and what relationship that has to the
state of
Israel I will try thank you I'll do my
best uh as as I said to you before we
started recording as a you know Common
citizen in the street I have the basic
knowledge of our relationship with
Palestine and uh how it came to be um
there is a lot of history behind this
but I can say that the Gaza Strip which
is a large area today populated by by
more than two million
Palestinians um most of them were
historically refugees that did not
receive home in any other Arab country
and uh there are history stories telling
you that uh many Arab countries did not
want to take on the Palestinians and so
um they ended up there and also in the
Judean samarra area uh the West Bank
What's called the West Bank so Palestine
is essentially two pieces of land uh in
in the small area of Israel which is
very similar to New Jersey you have Gaza
down south near uh the beach with the
Mediterranean and then you have the West
Bank which is around the Jerusalem area
inland on the um West area of Israel and
they're detached there is no physical uh
physical connection between those two
areas but they both belong to the same
people the same I want to say state but
they don't have a state of their own yet
and they're being the same the same
population exactly and they're being uh
colonized or controlled by the Israeli
government for many many years now um
can I can I uh ask a question when you
say that these people are refugees are
you talking about them being refugees in
the aftermath of the formation of the
state of Israel in would it be
1967 yes many of them but also I think
from other Arab countries I I don't know
exactly so I don't want to say the wrong
thing but I think they also came from
other Arab countries that there were
Palestinians in other Arab countries
that kind of left there I'm not sure of
all the circumstan that led to that but
uh people that really didn't have a home
and so you have today you have a very
large population especially in Gaza um
they don't have their own
um like the permission from Israel to
set up their own
infrastructure uh critical
infrastructure they rely on Israel for a
lot of their infrastructure in energy
sometimes water um they don't have a
port they don't have the permission from
Israel to open their own port they do
have an airport uh but they can't they
cannot it's quite complicated they have
to fly out to other Arab countries and
fly out from there so their lives are
very complicated and uh there is a very
high population of of children like
young population in Gaza because it's a
it's a society that just grows
exponentially very very fast um
and I think that there I probably safe
to say that there wouldn't be many
families or people in the Gaza
Strip um that don't have a
direct connection to loss of a family
member or a friend you know that died
during the the past I don't know 40
years um because of the situ situation
so so I would say as a society the
society is is you know traumatic
post-traumatic Society they they
experience death they experience a lot
of um hardship they're very poor they're
being allowed to come to Israel to work
some of them uh and they have to go
through the border crossing in order to
do that and you've asked also what Hamas
is so Hamas hold on hold on before you
get there I I want to react to What
You've just said because I expect that
this this is not strange to me because
I've had this experience many times
talking to Israelis that there appears
to be a great deal more Nuance in the
conversation about the interaction with
the Palestinian population than there is
in the wider World The Wider world has a
cartoonish view of this conflict and
assumes frankly that the empathy which
is evident in what you just said is
absent from the Jewish population
looking at the plight of the
Palestinians and that's just simply not
the case there are those who have no
empathy but uh a tremendous number of
Israelis see the predicament uh with a
high level of nuance so am I correctly
inferring that you have I I was really
hoping that we would touch on this
because the situation between between
Israel and Palestine is so explosive and
it's so delicate and
fragile I always call it an explosive
Barrel it's a Detonator just waiting to
be sparked and it's very easy to trigger
hate and polarity when you speak about
this subject because you have to take
sides
immediately and when you are an
Israeli that I'm not saying I'm not
taking sides I'm not saying anything
about sides I'm just saying when you're
an Israeli and you show
empathy to other people that are your
neighbors that are living you know 40
minutes away from you you are being
attacked and uh and it's wrong and you
shouldn't have that because you should
be on one position only now the the I
I'm struggling with that because on the
one hand i'm Israeli and my identity is
firmly ground in Israel and my my
ancestors and everything and I'm Jewish
um and at the same time am I correct you
are the the granddaughter of Holocaust
Survivors correct and my grandparents
after the second world war when they
came to Israel they they essentially
built kibuts in Israel and they were the
people that really helped build the the
new Israel after
1948 and so it's it's very you know what
I what I have is the ability I guess to
hold a very
complex problem and not to try and
deterministically find the answer or the
solution I'm okay with holding the
complexity without trying to you know
have one answer or one Clarity I don't
think it's possible the situation is so
complex that you have to look at
everything thing I mean it's it's not
easy but when you zoom out and you look
at things from you know far out you you
can try and find some empathy and and
also realize that you know evil is
everywhere and bad is everywhere in any
society and it doesn't mean that
everyone is bad it doesn't mean that
everyone's evil and we've seen some evil
stuff in the past few years but uh but
it's you know you got to do this
distinction or separation between the
Palestinian people and Hamas or
terrorists and there are many terrorists
or many bad people yes so let me uh let
me translate a little bit of that into
language that my my viewers will be
familiar with from from our podcast
there is a tension between two versions
of the way the world may
function one of them I describe maybe
incorrectly but for lack of a better
term I describe as the West MH the the
idea of the West is not that we should
forget where we come from but that where
you come from what population you come
from should not provide you advantages
and it shouldn't dictate with whom you
cooperate with that we should put those
things aside we should put our lineage
aside and collaborate with those who
bring things to the table that would be
useful in our collaboration that is the
idea of the West and it is a superior
way of being it's fairer it's less
violent it is more
liberating and then there is the way
that the world has worked until the West
which is lineage against lineage
competition and the predicament for
Israel as I see it and again I am no
expert in the situation of Israel but if
I view it through that lens Israel
firmly has one foot in each of these
worlds and it does not freely have the
ability to choose which World it lives
in because
neighboring states are at
least uh historically hellbent on
effectively the the rules of the prior
world and the unfortunate thing about
the superior putting lineage aside way
of interacting is that it is very
powerful it generates a tremendous
amount of wealth and well-being but it
is fragile and that means that those who
wish to opt out of it have veto power
over it and so Israel I see as caught in
this bind and the
tendency of people to default to
thinking of this conflict in lineage
terms is so unfortunate because it
misses the opportunity that exists if
only we can figure out how it might be
architected so I I see this as uh like a
NeverEnding tragedy the opportunity for
the Middle East to step away from
lineage and to be enriched across the
board exists yeah but we fail to move in
the right direction decade after decade
and I will also say before you answer my
question about uh what Hamas
is taking
sides is artificially narrowing of
perspective on the other
hand you know I'm told by people who
wish to change my perspective that what
I saw
um on my various screens as the attack
unfolded is propaganda and I believe I
have thrown out as much propaganda as I
can manage but what I'm left with are
things that Hamas itself uploaded wished
me to see and these things were so
barbaric that you know there is one part
of the story that is utterly ambiguous
and there is only one right side anybody
who committed these acts or planned
these acts or allowed these
acts is um
diabolical and anybody who understood
what took place and celebrated it is
similarly I think in a indefensible
position that said those who wish to
generalize that view onto an entire
population of people they know nothing
about uh are committing a grave error at
the very least they are failing to
understand the nature of what happened
so I I I I'm looking forward to hearing
your reactions to either of those things
that I've just
mentioned well first of all thanks for
translating my words to a lot more
sophisticated points of view I I love it
um
it's so difficult because what you're
saying is true there was a deadly
barbaric act committed in the past few
days and it's so easy to look at it and
say okay we need to wipe out Gaza now
but then you look at Gaza like the Hall
of Gaza what we just spoke about is that
the solution I think there is a solution
out there like you said and it can be
found but I think the people that are
pulling the strings are having a hard
time controlling the Beast that was
created right with time and so they may
be and maybe I'm very careful in saying
maybe they may be allowing things to
unfold that will help them create a new
pathway
to creating a new order in that area and
so if that's the case
then I think the prime minister of of
Israel is in a very tough position both
from the west west meaning the Biden
Administration and the
US um who is the biggest Ally for Israel
and on the other side from bricks
Nations uh including Saudi Arabia that
are trying to find a way to make the
Middle East more
peaceful because they need the Middle
East and Israel specifically as a super
strategic point to pass Commodities
around to control the world to you know
to have a infrastructure of gas and oil
Etc and Israel is is for for that reason
I think the prime minister of Israel is
getting pressured from both sides and
that's why I also think that what we're
seeing happening right
now should be maybe it's early that
we're having this discussion I don't
know but should be detached from the
this the the horrible incidents that
we've seen in the past few days and then
looking at it from a zoomed out
perspective of what are the bigger
Powers here that are trying to control
this area and why and so yeah I fully
agree with you that um looking at it
from a lineage point of view will end up
in the same place that we ended up many
many times before and if what we want is
to create something new and to bring
peace then we have to change something
in how we look at it and there is in
fact um a very long history
of Arab states
experimenting with the idea of a new
world in which lineage does not dominate
our interactions and I
remember I wasn't expecting this to be
emotional for me maybe for you but I
remember the assassination of
Sadat um who attempted to
partner I'm sorry no that's fine we are
being pushed into a tragedy what is
about to happen in Gaza is a tragedy and
it is a
tragedy that Hamas wanted and whoever
their partners are wanted the
overreaction of Israel to what took
place is inevitable and that's what the
barbarism was
about and I it is very
hard to
accept that bad people who are willing
to do that to innocent folks on either
side have such
control over our future as a planet and
this isn't just about the Middle East no
the world fac huge setback yeah yeah I'm
sorry
thank you for sharing that no I totally
see it like that
and and I think
that well I always said that we're
facing a few strategic points in the
world right now that are detonators like
Taiwan and China like Israel Palestine
and Ukraine Russia yep and I guess we
got to that second step after Ukraine
powers for the US are uh not as
effective anymore as Biden would have
liked I guess so they they're it's a
it's as if they're pulling the next step
in the plan and uh I was dreading this
day and we're there now my only hope is
that this will not spark the third world
war um but that is very much on the
table and people on the table it is but
uh yeah can talk about that later
maybe so let me return us to an earlier
point in the conversation I'd asked you
to describe as best you can what Hamas
is for people who uh you know know the
name but little
more
so it's hard to say this but Israel has
helped establish Hamas early on I think
it was 1967 when it
started and um Kamas was the beginning U
movement and with with
time it received more and more power and
more and more
um influence and uh incentives from
different powers around the
world Iran is one of them Israel was one
of them for a while Qatar I mean there
were different Messengers that were
using Hamas as a um tool to spark
conflicts with Israel uh it was very
convenient that they are situated
convenient right situated in the Gaza
Strip um amongst
civilian spots like like uh you know
churches and mosks and hospitals and
schools in fact it's a favorite tactic
of theirs to do their dirty work where a
response will inevitably kill Innocents
which will bring sympathy correct and
and that's their tactic and it works for
many many years I remember that from
when I was a soldier that there would be
no clean that it was it was very very
hard to create a clean work in the Gaza
Strip because you had to have some
casualties um you know overheads uh for
whatever operation that Israel has per
formed in the Gaza Strip now in 2005
Israel pulled out of the Gaza Strip and
Hamas became stronger and stronger when
Israel military is not inside the uh the
the strip anymore uh the control I would
say of the Israeli um forces over Hamas
is done through intelligence
forces um there are various various um
sorry
organizations that are in charge of
keeping in touch with the Hamas
um spying on them you know knowing
everything they do in order to control
them uh they have grown in the past few
years to really large uh Dimensions that
I think that even Israel knows today and
definitely Abu maen the the prime
minister of of
Palestine they both know that they
cannot control Hamas anymore and it
became that's what I called the beast
before right um it's very powerful it
controls the population speaking of
propaganda it's great in recruiting
young children to its forces very early
on there is heavy mind control in the
strip to um just grow this
organization's Dimensions to to really
large scale and
um recent questions that are popping up
um you may have seen this from really
from the past few days is about the
weapon systems of Hamas they are being
sponsored by different countries in the
Arab world um but recently there have
been voices saying how come Hamas is
holding weapons that are American
weapons how did it get to them this was
Afghanistan for example from Afghanistan
from Ukraine maybe yeah heavy Black
Market of
Weaponry it's just I I just recall the
this image of the stock exchange in the
US with the military industrial complex
stocks of locked Martin going up now all
the other companies war is great for
someone right
so there there are weapon systems ample
weapon systems in in the Gaza Strip in
Hamas um as well as in the West Bank um
and obviously kisah up North but you
know that's that's another organization
now some people during this attack you
see online many people refer to the
Hamas as Freedom Fighters again that's
another tactic for the divide and Rule
you cannot look at what they're doing
and call that
freedom um it's a it's a terror
organization the truth has to be said do
you know I realize that some of the
people who support Hamas probably do so
under duress or under false pretenses
but do you have any idea within the
Palestinian population how popular Hamas
actually is I think they are very I
don't know to say say numbers or or
refer to like very accurate information
but they are very popular and they are
stronger their influence is stronger
than the influence of Abu Mazen and I
think that's one of the problems that
Israel and Abu Mazen when they try to
negotiate peace Deals they have a
problem called Hamas what are we doing
with that organization that is in the
way in a way so there needs to be I I
would speculate that there needs to be a
good justification to take down
Hamas and surprise surprise I think we
have one now well the justification for
eliminating Hamas is crystal clear the
question of how one does that with Hamas
intermingled with innocent people is
another question entirely
um but all right so I think you've
painted a a fairly clear picture let's
get to the uh the
Central Point that uh caused me to focus
on on your work and and brought us into
this
conversation when I saw the attacks my
first thought
literally
was how is this even possible on that
border that it could be breached by so
many people simultaneously one one would
have expected if an attack had been
successful that the number of people got
through initially would have been small
you know if five people had gotten
through out of a a a uh a military force
of a hundred and had done some damage
that would certainly be noteworthy and
would be considered an embarrassing
failure for the IDF and the security
services of Israel but to have hundreds
get through and operate um barely
impeded for was it a full day almost
this
seems like it is not if if somebody
submitted it as a script you would say
that is
implausible and so it did lead me to
wonder what could possibly explain such
a failure incompetence seems
inadequate to explain it now you're in a
position to say more about this because
you have you have manned that
border
yeah it's very hard for me to talk about
it because it's
um there are so many friends and family
members of friends that are missing and
have been taken hostage in this barbar
barbaric acts that talking about what I
know feels like sometimes feels like why
is this important now and at the same
time I know that if we don't talk about
this then we will just let them off the
hook once again because to me and and I
will explain why I think this this
is a great atrocity um because to me
this
is
it's I don't know how to say it it's
just the people of Israel have been I
don't know if sacrifice is too rough of
a word but we have been
sold and uh sold out completely and
uh no help for hours and hours and no
military involvement no police no arms
on the ground for hours and hours this
is something that is non-typical and
unusual for Israel Defense Forces now
I've served in the military forces 25
years ago as uh I was in the
intelligence forces based in the Gaza
Strip as I told you and I know the
security drills when I served there was
no internet so I would sit next to the
phone in my uh shift of the fence of the
security of the Gaza Strip and whenever
something would move alongside the fence
I would get a phone call from the human
observers that are looking at the gate
um telling us there is a chain of
command that you have to notify when
something like this happens and then
straight away uh forces come in to look
at what is it and take it down so what
do you mean when something moves by the
fence how small it can be a pig it can
be a cat moving alongside the fence or
touching the fence or trying to cross
the fence an animal they would identify
it they would see it there are cat a cat
gets trigger yeah it could trigger the
fence yeah an animal 25 years later with
and 25 years later with internet and
with the most sophisticated high-tech
weaponary systems like drones like there
is a special system I don't know how to
call it in English uh it's called Uh
seeing shooting that's a literal
translation from Hebrew to to English
seeing shooting it's a robot that sits
on top of a of a um a tower looking
looking at the fence and whenever
something triggers the fence which has
sensors on it it's supposed to shoot
it's like automatic right and and there
are drones and there are helicopters and
there are troopers on the ground and you
know there are many things that are
supposed to be activated there are
various lines of defense and layers of
defense that are supposed to be
activated when something like that
happens okay so so I just want to make
this clear I mean it probably is but you
have a system that is sensitive to
anything the size of a cat or bigger
that system since you were uh Manning it
has had 25 years to mature and
become more sensitive to become more
Discerning and yet how many places was
that border breached 15 15 places yeah
15 and that is completely ridiculous
because normally with one breach of the
fence the whole Army is triggered and
things start moving immediately things
start moving immediately and here there
was nothing for hours and so I was I
want to talk about some of the
explanations that have been given so
far there are some unbacked I have to
say that these explanations are unbacked
by any evidence or proof so far but they
have been thrown out to the air or to
the mainstream media it started with
Iranian Cyber attack that took down the
IDF Tech infrastructure that was running
around for a while okay that because
they took down the the the IDF
technology infrastructure there was no
way for the technology to operate all
right let me just let me just highly
unlikely even if it was true one would
imagine that
especially was it within one day of the
50th anniversary of the Yum kipur War
there is a Cyber attack that doesn't
result in every person being called up
simultaneously and placed on whatever
border is most likely to be breached
under those conditions yeah I mean
wouldn't it that's of course that's why
it's completely unlikely and what about
the backup systems and how come and then
I'm asking myself okay if this is true
then how come all the civilian
infrastructure was still working we had
no problem with any other infrastructure
just the IDF one was was hurt this just
doesn't add up and then it moved on to
The Narrative of a takedown of the
Observer Lookouts including the human
Observer soldiers that were there they
said that they that the terrorists came
into the um bunker and just you know
murdered or killed everyone we still
don't know if this is true or not but
that was that seem like a simple factual
question yeah and we don't know there
was no explanation or or fact released
to us about that it was just a rumor
again were such a thing to have happened
the I don't think you need to be a
military strategist to imagine that the
next thing you do is Marshall an
overwhelming Force to the area that has
just been blinded by the
murder of the people manning the Border
correct and yet that did not
happen no it did not happen and then you
get some other soldiers um talking on
social media saying tweeting on social
media saying that leave The Observers
alone they were Heroes they did notify
they were there and they were they
notified the forces that they were
supposed to notify but no one answered
so again who know it's it's again
another contradiction we don't know and
then the next thing that happened it was
this morning when I received this
information that Air Force pilots shared
stories on their Twitter account it's in
Hebrew that they were up in the air
fighting and protecting already 45
minutes after the breaches now that is
I'm sorry to say it like that blatantly
that is a lie Li because we have people
on the ground in all the different
villages in the Gaza envelope area
around the Gaza Strip that they see
every movement in the sky whenever
there's a helicopter or a jet or
anything they know there was nothing for
hours in the sky so why would the Air
Force pilots now tweet and say we were
there within 45 minutes fighting and
taking down terrorists no they weren't
so and so these narratives are being
thrown out to the air there is no
official statement about any of these
that I told you about it's only in the
public
discussion and the administration is not
even trying to give us any answers
they're saying we're fighting now we'll
talk about it later kind of
approach yes and unfortunately that has
an eerie ring to other events this and
yes it's almost as
if whatever arranged this and let us
agree that at the very least this was
not Hamas acting independently they were
at least backed by Iran and that
suggests that there were at least
Regional forces in play possibly Global
forces but whatever it
is that arranged
this there is a component on the Israeli
side that is mysterious
and there is no effort being put
into an explanation that could possibly
satisfy anybody with let's say your
level of understanding of what took
place there these are transparently
inadequate explanations being offered
and the only defense of them is that to
entertain any alternative possibility
will be dismissed as conspiracy
theorized correct and what you're saying
is so true that it's actually happening
I will explain in a second I'll just I
just want to say something about what
you said about Iran I'm not sure that
Iran is behind this although the
mainstream media Wall Street Journal is
saying that they are um isn't Iran
saying that it is Iran is not saying
that it is the president of Iran is
actually saying we are not behind this
but we kiss the hands of Hamas for doing
what they did we support them but we are
not behind this now that is complicated
and and the thing is just because a
journalist now and I try to be factual
Israel does not have any evidence at the
moment that Iran is behind this so we
just have to we just have to hold that
okay I I I want to be careful because we
don't know it may have been by the way a
a Hamas soldier that was captured by the
Israeli Defense Forces now in the last
couple of days in his investigation he
said that they were working on this
drill for one year they were planning
and and and preparing for this for one
year
and that they were shocked that the IDF
did not show up until five hours
later and uh and he said he said another
thing he said that uh he said that they
were the one I mean he said it was their
initiative he didn't mention Iran at all
he said that they were working on it
with 1,000 soldiers now as I said before
Hamas did grow to really big dimensions
and they do have a lot of weaponry and a
lot of sophistication and they should
not be disrespected in terms of military
power and so it is possible that they
did it themselves the the only thing I
would speculate is that they were
supposed to come in and do a a
smaller scenario a smaller event but
since they bumped into this party they
did an Isis trick that didn't end well
that's what I speculate I don't know if
it was planned to be that big as it was
and very gory and I have really gory
descriptions which we will not go into
but the it's I don't know if they had
planned all of what has happened in such
detail well if I if I put together the
pieces that I've seen and again I am no
expert in what takes place in the Middle
East
but a there are two contradictions here
or two
implausible um
claims one that the failure at the
Israeli
border
was
organic there is at least not a
sufficient explanation that is on the
table yet that would explain both the
failure of the detection
and the failure in the absence of the
detection of an overwhelming Force
showing up immediately one of those two
things if the if the if the detection
failed the IDF should have shown up in
force immediately and the fact that it
didn't suggest two failures but the
other thing I want to point out is that
Israel is
now um
devastating Gaza yes it is claiming to
be
bombing the sites in which
Hamas conducts its
operations to say that this operation
which was being planned for a year and
was massive went
undetected and now to be claiming that
in fact they are being that that it may
look to us like they're blowing up
apartment buildings but that's because
there's a weapons Factory in the the
basement that suggests a high level of
knowledge of where these actions are
actually
conducted and a high level of knowledge
and a long period of planning in which
the attack was not
anticipated that is simply uh
incompatible and that's the other thing
about my military experience I was in
the intelligence forces the the shift I
told you about about picking the phone
and knowing what happens around the
fence that was only one time a week all
the rest of my time was in intelligence
work so I know how the system works in
terms of knowing about every little step
that Hamas is taking in the Gaza Strip
we have human informers and you know
many other tactics to know what is
happening in the Gaza Strip you know I
don't need to go into the details people
who see spy movies know but in all
exists and so for one year this has been
planned and the shabbach or the h200 or
whatever the intelligence forces did not
know the Mad did not know of anything
highly highly highly unlikely okay um
and then you asked you said something
you mentioned something about they are
supposed to bring in the forces even if
there were so many breaches where were
the forces so I want to answer to that
the Gaza division was actually moved to
the Judea and Samaria area near
Jerusalem almost in its entirety 60 to
80% of this Battalion was moved to that
area some of the most professional
battalions in the IDF were moved there
to secure illegal outposts in the
Samaria and secure a member of
parliament in a village called Kara a
Palestinian Village because it's one of
those member of parliaments that likes
to provoke and you know he's a settler
he wants to be there in the middle of a
Palestinian Village and so he needs
protection from the Army and so a lot of
you know that's one of the things about
the current Israeli Administration that
has a lot of
ministers or or U members of the
parliament that are
extreme it's rightwing like they're
settlers hardliners yeah oh completely
and so they're and they're very
provocative and they demand a lot of
protection from the Army from Benjamin
nanyo and he succumbs to that to to
their demands and so a lot of the forces
that were supposed to be around Gaza
were not there and this I would point
out again I don't think you have to be a
military strategist to figure out why
you wouldn't want to move that entire
force even if you had to borrow half of
it you would certainly leave the other
half there and you would leave them in
an activated State because there's a
diminished capacity that does not seem
to me like that requires a tremendous
amount of understanding the other thing
is to move that force on the 50th
anniversary of the Yum Kapur
War seems Preposterous
correct yes so
and yeah go ahead and I want to I want
to add one last thing about all this I
watched um Mike Ben explaining really
well in his recent video um how he
follows internet censorship as detecting
leads lead indicators to finding answers
about things and if you want to know if
you get you want to get some clues about
what's happening here right now there is
a clear attempt in the Israeli Main
stream media to silence any voices which
are asking how come something like this
has happened they're calling any
question like the ones I'm asking fake
news and this part of the propaganda is
starting okay so so that's a for me this
is a clue they don't want us to ask the
questions so let us also point out the
interesting possibly just coincidental
fact that Mike Ben has just faced a um a
character
assassination uh that has made uh just a
few days a few days before the attack
and so it is possible that that is
happen stance um Mike has done a great
job of revealing the censorship
industrial complex and uh they would of
course have an incentive to take him
down at any moment but Coincidence of
him being uh
hobbled um just before this attack in
which the censorship was going to kick
into high gear is at least worth
noticing you know wow I didn't know that
right so there's that I did want to ask
you um the view in the west which I
suspect is um overly
simplistic is that the failure that
allowed this to happen is so
glaring that Benjamin Netanyahu will not
politically survive this chapter and the
reason that I don't think that that's
accurate is
that the Bush
Administration had a similar
failure and one could have made the same
argument that it was so embarrassing
that this could have happened the 911
attacks could have happened on their
watch that bush could not survive but of
course um it empowered him so I'm not
sure one interpretation is that whatever
arranged this and I'm fascinated to hear
you say it very interesting for Iran to
bless the attack without taking
credit it's they're paying much of the
price just simply to embrace it and then
to say actually this wasn't us I don't I
certainly don't take them at their word
on the other hand that's an interesting
way to divide the
responsibility um so the question is
what did arrange this um Hamas clearly
arranged it did they have
help did they have
someone who understood what was taking
place and decided it was better to allow
it to
happen were they supplied by large
forces was there a desire to upend the
um the Saudi Accord which has was
successful you know so what we have is
the
usual what has become the usual
implausible pattern of anomalies there
will always be anomalies in historical
events those who are
um uh guilty of what a statistician
might call overfitting Will patterns
where they're not there but at this
point in history we have a great many
historical events that just simply have
too many anomalies to be organic there
is some way in which we know at least we
are not getting the full story and in
this case you have the obvious story I
think we've oh there you are um we have
the obvious story of um Hamas attacking
Southern Israel
that one is unignorable because we see
it rendered in video we have a larger
Regional story potentially involving
Iran and Saudi
Arabia and then we have also a global
story in
which you say um war is always good for
someone and those someone's aren't
inherently in the Middle East in fact
many of them simply won't be so
let us at least take on the
sophistication of
recognizing that given how much is at
stake in the battle that has now
erupted that it would be naive to
imagine that the players don't know on
which side their bread is buttered and
that they are not acting accordingly and
may have acted accordingly prior to the
outbreak of any obvious
violence yes and um
you know another point that I want to
add to that which is interesting
speaking of the narratives or the clues
that we get from the mainstream media is
that we've seen in the past few days
many narratives coming from Global media
about what's happening now in Gaza and
Israel is the Israeli 911 or the Israeli
Pearl Harbor and it's mainstream media
that is making those parallels and I'm
asking myself why what what is behind
this because we know what has happened
before the before Pearl Harbor and what
happened after 911 we know what kind of
triggering of bigger events have
happened after that are they trying to
prepare the audience for something
bigger to
come well it's funny those
comparisons um have exactly the opposite
ring to me they're almost like an
admission
because although I don't think we have a
good understanding of either event
there's the implication in both events
that there may have been um awareness at
least yeah uh and that that awareness
suggests larger forces in
play and I think this
is believe me I'm anything but
comfortable saying this and I know that
you're not comfortable uh in this
territory but the idea that we um we
little people are
being played and pushed into a battle in
which we will lose a tremendous amount
for reasons that we can't understand
because we're not at the table and we
don't hear the discussions and we don't
know what the objectives
are um is almost in
escapable and it is the reason that we
have to have these conversations is we
have to stop stop being manipulable yeah
into conflicts that are serving someone
else at our expense whoever it may
be and you you mentioned there the um
Saudi deal right and the trying to
normalize the efforts between uh trying
to normalize a peace deal between Israel
and Palestine and I wonder to myself
whether a prison ER exchange deal is
something that could only be seriously
considered by Israel if a shocking event
like that happened like did you know did
they need such a such an atrocity in
order to justify us releasing really
dangerous prisoners from Israel security
prisoners or is there a bigger play here
to try and wipe out Kamas which abum
masan cannot control as I said before or
even Benjamin canot control and try and
get a peace deal with pulling out like
maybe it's an exchange deal of Israel
pulling out its settlements from Jude
and Samar area which is a big problem on
the table when you come to talk about
the peace process so is it okay we'll
pull out from there in exchange to those
hostages and I mean but you have to
justify to the Israeli people so did you
need such a big thing in order to you
know uh build your path towards
this and and again this is this is just
my speculations
because the you even heard yesterday the
um Deputy Kamas leader Sal alari
suggesting using Israeli prisoners for
leverage in negotiations it say and and
that happened very I I think it was even
two days ago it happened almost
immediately after they captured them
it's as if they were doing it in order
to have it in order to say it you know
it's
so well let me say um I think we're
damned if we do and damned if we don't
with respect to having these
conversations obviously we are at a
tremendous disadvantage in terms of
knowing what's really going on in inside
of any of these things because I think
it is fair to say you and I are both
Outsiders to all of it but not
discussing it leaves us as Pawns in a
game we do not understand and that is uh
a terrible position to find ourselves in
the one thing that does not fit about
the narrative you have just
proposed I think
is the
barbaric
atrocities that were
committed had this been a
strategically careful
operation had
they grabbed
prisoners and not harmed
them their
leverage would be greater I
think I agree but since Hamas is Hamas
and it's a terrorist organization it's
not
a it's not a well-regulated force it's
not a well-regulated force but it's also
it's made of really evil people it may
have gone out of control all I'm saying
is that it was maybe it was supposed to
be something like that and it went out
of control and became right especially
given how if we take the captured Hamas
member at his word which there's no
reason we should but um there's also no
obvious reason that he would lie about
it uh the fact that Hamas was
surprised at their success means that
likely they were not planning for the
level of access that they would gain and
therefore uh it is possible that what
unfolded on the ground was you know
their nature coming out in light of um
surprising failure yeah we're succeeding
big time here so we should pile up yeah
kind yeah and and one last point about
that the there is a retired General his
name is itak Brick he said that Gad
Eisen Cott which was the former IDF
chief of general staff fought to hide
his report on the idf's unpreparedness
for
war and brick said this in April this
year and also a few weeks ago in an
interview and many many times before
that Israel is not ready for an allout
war and and laid out the reasons for it
and he's been knocking on the doors of
the Prime Minister and the higher
Generals in the Army and the Minister of
Defense but no one would listen to him
and he was also banned from mainstream
media they would not give him a stage
and this is a retired general of the IDF
right is not someone that came from the
street analyzing what they're doing it's
coming from within the system and he's
saying we are not prepared if something
like this is about to happen so he's
like pointing on all the different flaws
of the army that maybe you know and I
know that I'm now complicating this even
more because I'm saying maybe really the
IDF was not ready and something really
bad is going on in the IDF since I was
there 25 years ago I don't
know well let me um it's just fair to
put that on the table as well I think
yes and I and I think we are uh not only
well within our rights of citizens who
interests uh are tied up in events over
which we have no
control um but I think we are also
obligated to have this discussion and
because we are left only with the
evidence we can see and the ability to
extrapolate I I think we have to and we
are bound to get some stuff wrong and
what we have to do is just commit as we
discover that we have got something
wrong to fix it um but I I want to go
back to something you said at the
beginning which struck me as important
and potentially
relevant
you said that
Hamas was in some way a
creation of Israel or words to that
effect I don't want to put words in your
mouth do you want to describe what the
early
relationship that you were alluding to
is because it may be that we are looking
at an evolved version of that same
relationship
yes I would love that but I am no expert
in that so I don't want to say things
that are wrong and uh I I want to be
responsible here because there is a
history about it I need to go back and
look at my notes and read more about it
before I answer this uh I know that
Israel was the one that sponsored and
created the organization and with with
the different administrations that have
changed during the years that were
different relationships with this
organization but again I don't want to
bring the details because I don't have
them on me and and as I said I'm not an
expert so I I don't want to go into it
too much so that does I appreciate your
caution um it does remind me I think
there are a number of different examples
in history but Afghanistan uh for the
United States is clearly one
where we appear to have created a
force uh in the era where it was
fighting the Russians um that became a
monster which which uh haunted uh
our uh our later
Incarnation um so creating a monster
that you can't control is an old story
yeah um but there is also the
possibility you know what I increasingly
think is that
um we Outsiders we citizens of the world
who
are trying to live better
lives are unfortunately mesmerized by
anachronisms of the
map right we look at Israel and we see a
flag with a Jewish star and we look at
the border fence and we see a population
that is not free to come and go
and we imagine that these must be the
objects in play on the chessboard and we
just fail to grasp that
actually um nation states are not what
they once were and there are forces that
are as big as nation states or bigger
that operate without names that we know
or if we know their names we
misunderstand the magnitude of their
power and the nature of it
and so what it means is we are we are
easily pushed into things based on a
narrative that isn't actually even
highly relevant to the events it's the
narrative that is delivered for um I
don't want to say our benefit but it is
delivered in order to control our
mindset surrounding these things it
inflames predictable tensions in order
to accomplish ends that may have nothing
to do with those tensions uh um
so and everything is so shallow in the
in most of the Public's
perception of what's happening in
reality and most people look
at what the government is doing what the
in this case Defense Forces are doing
and they
refuse to take on the point of view that
there may be higher powers that are
manipulating this they simply refuse
under the uh cognitive dissonance that
they're in under the influence of the
indoctrination of the army of the
different systems that are running at
play not just in Israel but all around
the
world and whenever you suggest something
that is outside I call it the sandbox of
allowed rules which you can play this
game in this Matrix
then you're being you know you're being
tagged and and and shamed and called
names and and because of
that I don't know if it's hubris or or
um or or the cognitive dissonance that
is controlling here but because of that
phenomena we are not able as a species
not just as Israelis or Jewish or or you
know Palestinians or whatever but just
as human species we're unable to expand
our perception and Consciousness to to
there is something more here than the
five senses that we have or the rules of
the game that we are being allowed to
play and that is this is my only hope
from all this crazy shenanigan that is
going around in Israel and around the
world that people will start asking
questions because that's the only way
way to start waking up the mind that is
so heavily controlled I think you have
you have hit the nail on the head and in
particular I think it is the terror that
people experience over the stigmas that
will be de directed at them if they
contemplate these things that keeps them
uh they Purge their own minds of the
awareness yes that they would otherwise
have so as not to be caught in
possession of legal thoughts
yes and we we saw that over coid where
because of uh what I now know about our
meeting I know you and I are uh of like
mind on this front that a a story
unfolded surrounding coid that we do not
know um and we are left with a
tremendous amount of evidence but it
tells an incomplete story about who who
was driving and for what reason
um but
the the only people who know anything
about what happened during coid are
people who stared down those
stigmas and decided to endure them in
order to see what was on the other side
and I think we are in the same place
here that we have a puzzle
with many parties that have interests
named and unnamed some of which may just
be lucky or unlucky bystanders some of
which may have been motivating some of
which may be painted as having motivated
or participated even though they did not
and I I
uh I have always liked the part of Harry
Potter where Harry Potter is the one guy
who doesn't worry about saying
Voldemort
and I think get a
deep yeah so I'm going to speak the name
of Voldemort here I'm going to say that
there is something there is a thought
that will not let me go in looking at
the aftermath of October 7th's
attack which is that years
ago the
neocons wanted to remake the map of the
Middle East with American Military
mind that was their plan and it involved
battles which they had reason to
want and they partially got their way
and it was of course a
disaster
but this does the fact that uh we have
all who have paid any attent I mean I
have avoided the mainstream press on
this issue as much as possible and thank
goodness that uh Twitter as broken as it
is provides a semi-free space in which
we can at least exchange evidence and
debate
it um but there is a way in which
the portrayal of Iran's of Iran's
role would function as a continuation of
that neocon plan a Revival of it in the
aftermath of the debacle in
Iraq so I don't know if that's a driving
force here or not
but um I certainly think it is incumbent
on the citizens of the world not to be
pushed into actions over a simplistic
narrative that cannot possibly account
for the events that we have
seen I'm with you and uh I think that um
the fact that there are higher Powers
geopolitically at Play especially with
Russia and
China that are behind the scenes Putin
is today by the way said that he's uh
supporting Hamas but
um we know that Iran is one of the
largest players in the world for oil and
gas we know its importance we know that
the US position as the
anglo-american
um for get the the the
word that would be something we'll have
to edit um aony hemony yes no we don't
have to edit that that's perfect English
is not your first language the fact that
you even know the word hegemony is uh is
wonderful so I think the fact that we're
going into in a way that it looks like
an unstable Emy for the US and towards
the end of this
monetary control for the US with the
dollar and the bricks coming in to
destabilize the power of the dollar um
Iran is playing a very important role
here and I think that Iran Saudi Arabia
and the rest of the bricks countries as
I said before have an interest of
keeping the Middle East relatively quiet
whereas the US may have an interest to
keep the Middle East burning or at least
sparking some kind of
um trying to lure in maybe Iran into a
war well I'm going to quibble with you
in one way it's very minor though it's
very major as well it's not the US that
might have that interest it is the thing
that has captured our system you know
rather like the Palestinians who are now
going to suffer the Wrath that will
naturally respond to Hamas the American
public most certainly does not have an
interest in a for sure chaotic Middle
East oh
no but that doesn't mean and this was I
thought the strength of what Mike Benz
put out it alerted me to a whole
dimension of this
puzzle I don't know why I wasn't
thinking about it obviously one should
think about fossil fuels when one thinks
about the Middle East because it is a a
major Force but what he called my
attention
to was I forgive me if I get the numbers
wrong but he said uh Iran is sitting on
the third largest oil deposit and the
second largest uh natural gas gas
deposits on Earth and that this
actually interrelates the story in the
Middle East with the story in Ukraine uh
especially with respect to Europe's need
for liquefied natural gas the nordstream
pipeline Etc so uh I Iran can be the new
supplier of of energy for Europe right
right and uh I don't know you probably
will not be aware of this but I've
deployed a uh a principle on
Darkhorse um that I call the time
traveling money printer and the idea is
we all understand how to make money if
you have a time machine there are no
time machines but you can create
something that works just like one by
slowing down everyone else's awareness
of what's taking place because it allows
you to predict events in the world and
if you can predict events in the world
you can bet on them in the market and
when you bet on them in the market you
can effectively print money you steal
that money from the rest of us and we
don't even notice right we Face
inflation we don't know why we face you
know the downturn in the market where
we're in invested and an upturn in the
stocks that you're invested in because
you knew what was going to happen and we
didn't it basically turns the
population of the world into greater
fools and U in any case my point would
be in manting
reality manufacturing reality I would
point out what does manufacturing
reality look like it looks
like absolute
barbarism conducted against Real Inn
citizens and then broadcast to the
Internet so the callousness that is
required to operate the time traveling
money printer is
ghastly right it manifests as the
torment and destruction of innocent
people but for anyone willing to do that
and I think coid reveals that there are
at least some very powerful people who
are uh unbothered by the destruction of
innocent lives
um that for anyone willing to do that it
is
a um a game at which they can become
highly expert and Escape any control
that we might wish to exert through the
normal structures that Society depends
on because if you if you can print money
by predicting events or even more
powerfully creating events that you can
then predict with
Precision um
then you are
freed from the mechanism that we usually
use to control things like um Espionage
organizations right the budget so it is
it is smart for us to recognize the
degree to which Our Lives life and
death exists Downstream of this
potential mechanism which a very
powerful fure
you uh are likely operating um regularly
and it likely explains events that we
then try to explain with much more
mundane tools which don't work yeah
because of course the nature of yeah you
and I can sit here and try to speculate
forever about what has happened and we
may never know of what has happened here
or what has happened at 911 or what has
happened in many other incidents in the
in the past but those people who are
behind pushing you called it you know
having the grip on the US and and on the
people of the US and pushing that boat
in the direction that it's going are
hidden from site we don't know who they
are we don't know what their motives are
we can guess and speculate and it's an
unfair game and the whole design of the
system that they have created is
definitely not in our favor it's never
in the favor of the small person
and I think the the money story tells a
lot not just who's making more money but
the actual design and architecture of
the monetary system and how it came to
be and why they have created it the way
it it has been created and the fact that
the the the sheer um design of that
system is dictating enslavement in a way
it's modern enslavement it's hidden from
our eyes we don't go we don't wake up in
the morning go to work feeling like a
slave we are being taught that that's
the normal way to live but when you
actually analyze and learn about how
money works and how the fiat currency
system works you understand that this is
a perfect design for those power that be
to manipulate the whole world and the
the small
person yeah it's a it's a kind of
surgical slavery where parts of you are
free right go get a tattoo you can curse
you know you are free in many ways but
you're not free in the ways that matter
and yeah that's why I call it the
sandbox because you have a border that
they've drawn for you you can play as
much as you want within that sandbox but
once you try and step out of that
sandbox see what happens
very diff oh very difficult so I think
um I think it's wise just for anybody
who's trying to figure out what to do
with the
uh um obvious dir of useful information
and the need to speculate where you just
simply don't have the right um access to
information is to consider you know is
the barbarism of Hamas in southern
Israel on October 7th actually the
result of a story involving liquid
natural gas that exists in Iran that
might be sold to Europe and that certain
powerful players might be aware
of um a way that they might get cut in
on the massive amount of uh wealth that
will be at least transferred if not
generated by such an event right again
it looks like barbarism on your screen
but it might be about money and natural
gas that isn't even on the map you were
looking at um so you know and you know I
what we haven't mentioned is that I'm
also
watching the events in
Israel had a profound effect on
alliances that were forming that were
going to have an effect on the American
election in
2024 now that could be pure happen
stance
um or not and it could also be in fact
it strikes me as rather likely that
whatever it is that is
steering events and of course it doesn't
steer them all they are bound to be
organic events but um whatever it is
that is steering
events um is
large
it there may be multiple things doing it
and they may be competing um
but there doesn't have to be
a single objective it can be that a
certain number of objectives would be
served by a certain kind of event and
that you know once you get a sufficient
number of check boxes checked then the
point is okay this one's worth making
happen and um and that means that those
of us who are trying to figure out
what's going on from the outside are
liable to uh settle on a single
explanation which will be wrong because
it's incomplete so we have to be aware
that we're
dealing with a complex system uh that we
have no ability to observe and learn
about it's all very indirect by by
Design I love the analysis of Katherine
Austin Fitz when she describes the
silos that the money people as she calls
them have when they design or or the the
the most powerful people in the world
and some of them are Bankers she says
they try to keep the silos intacted so
that you will not connect The Silo of
media to The Silo of Defense to The Silo
of Elections or Pol politics to The Silo
of money etc etc so that you will not
make these connections and see the
bigger picture you would think the
Israeli Gaza attack is really related
only to the conflict in the Middle East
and you would think that the elections
in the US is related only to the
elections in the US and Ukraine and
Russia is separate and it really blocks
you from seeing the bigger picture and I
think and that also takes me to sorry
it's like intuitive taking me to
remembering Edward Dow saying um that
when he
saw early on in 2020 the head of the
bank of international settlements the
bis when he saw him making a speech
saying
that they are about to
create um green passes or vaccine
passports that before the the vaccines
even came out and this is a banker a
mega Banker the the bis for those who
don't know is the Big Brother of of
central banks he's sitting there talking
about moving into a new system of
digital passports for vaccinations and
health and Edward Dow being a former uh
Black Rock analyst and a Wall Street guy
is looking at it saying that moment I
knew that this coid thing is way larger
than just health because if a banker is
sitting there talking to me about a
digital passport a vaccine passport then
they like he gave him the clue here's a
connection between those two silos that
you normally cannot see right so and you
have to be really sophisticated I think
in order to spot those small connections
between those silos because the system
will try to make it almost impossible
for you to detect them and so you have
to in a way that's why you know I like
the term conspiracy theorist because you
are open to so many ideas and to so many
different points of information and you
have the ability to try to and connect
them and you also need to have the
humility to say no with that connection
I was wrong and that's not a proper
Theory and I'm going to throw it away
but then you stay open and you know you
you take on more and you know I got
carried away but that just sparked this
for me no I get it um I will say uh in
my professional life I am a a theorist
I'm an evolutionary theorist and so I
think very carefully about how Theory
functions right it functions you don't
come up with a theory you come up with a
hypothesis the hypothesis predictions if
those predictions turn out to be true
then you tend to think your hypothesis
is probably overlapping reality so
there's a rigorous way to do Theory it
doesn't mean a guess yes so what I would
say
is for decades in fact partially
Downstream from the CIA which uh set
about poisoning the idea of conspiracy
theory the CIA actually um Advanced the
I the concept that the term conspiracy
theory should be used to dismiss
alternative explanations for the Kennedy
assassination but in any
case the point is they have now
overplayed their hand for years people
were spooked by the idea of Comm of
conspiracy theory now the question is
really not are you a conspiracy theorist
but are you good at it are you good at
being rigorous and throwing out bad
hypotheses of conspiracy and following
evidence to where it actually leads even
when it upends an idea that you looked
on favorably at first so that is
unfortunately where we are but I think
people are getting used to the idea that
it would be absurd given how much
collusion we've seen it would be absurd
to dismiss the idea of conspiracy out of
hand that's just naive yeah and I think
with the size of the Beast right now we
are going to see more and more um
narratives Collide we're going to see
more and more things that don't add up
that maybe even internal battles between
different powers of that beast and I
think this is to our advantage in a way
it's going to be very messy it's dirty
it's gory this is exactly what's
happening in Israel right now now but
it's revealing at the same time well I
like your point about um when we glimpse
a connection between silos that tells us
something like Edward Dow was uh
awakened to what coid was by a banker
talking about vaccine passports right
it's a classic moment um but it speaks
also to the
importance of just as we are jerked
around by events and simplistic
narratives that cause us to um to see
familiar lines on a map and think we
know what's going on um we are also
triggered
into um betrayals of people who are on
our team by these takedowns right the
mik Ben's
takedown
is particularly important in a world
where the glimpses of the connections
between silos are actually the map of
what's really taking place yes need not
many people can do what Mike Benz does
and whatever you know the takedown of
him I did not find very compelling they
they did find something that does have a
kind of moral complexity to it that
requires you to think very carefully
about to even know whether you're
comfortable with it but at the end of
the day Mike is playing such an
important role in revealing a world that
is controlling how we interact with each
other
that we ought to look at the fact that
something suddenly emerges about him
that causes us to feel one way or
another and say well why would that be
happening right why why are we suddenly
questioning Mike Ben why are we suddenly
questioning Russell Brand why are we
suddenly questioning Joe Rogan or Robert
Malone or any of the dissidents who have
proven that they can actually withstand
the stigmas and reveal things that
others cannot yeah the this is a very
important clue in deciphering the the
game that is being played against us and
I'm just hopeful that more and more
people will understand that when this
becomes so common and so um you know
with all the Miss and disinformation
laws now it's
becoming like they're trying to
normalize it and it is weird even to the
most normal Normy out there that they're
trying to silence so many people on so
many topics and I think that's where
they're gonna get a how do you call it
like um a foul like a like a like in
succer that you yeah a foul a foul right
yeah because they they they're
they're digging their own grave in a way
they're showing the normal people out
there that yeah we we we told you in the
past that you should behave a certain
way and you should comply with certain
rules and you should be in a certain way
in society but now we're enforcing all
these things in laws and we're hurting
people who are not doing that and they
are escalating this they are
exaggerating and I think this is their
mistake because it will wake more and
more people up um there's no question
that they are waking more and more
people up but I also think um it is very
important that we understand that that
was
not they did make an error but I don't
think it's exactly the one you've
described I think so another principle
that I uh took a long time to realize
but I I find very important is that what
we are facing ing in this complex
environment I call it Goliath Goliath is
the force that opposes meaningful change
and why doesn't it want meaningful
change because it's a winner and it can
only end up as a loser through change it
could stay a winner but in in general
change is not good for the winners so
they prevent it but Goliath that force
that prevents change has two parts it
has a part that colludes that knows what
it's doing that part is
intelligent it also has a part that's
emergent right people who realize that
they're going to be stigmatized if they
think one thing so they think another
and then they reinforce each other or
journalists who accidentally discover
that when they write stories that look
like this they don't do well and when
they write stories like like that
suddenly you know they're their quality
of life goes up so that they they don't
know why they're writing those stories
but something is paying them indirectly
something that will never meet so that
emergent part is dumb as hell just like
the real Goliath probably was the real
Goliath was probably a a giant meaning
that he had a pituitary tumor and he was
a dimwit and he was vulnerable and it
wasn't David who took him out but uh the
story is recorded as if it was David but
in any case
Goliath is partially an emergent force
and an emergent Force that's a synonym
for an evolved Force the thing about
evolved forces is they can be
ferociously
powerful when they are facing the thing
to which they
evolved they are
clumsy when they are facing something
novel that they have never seen before
right Goliath uh had never seen elhanan
who we record in the story as if it was
David right a little guy who understood
that this battle was not just about
Force but was about you know agility and
slingshots or
whatever that is something Goliath does
not anticipate and our Goliath did not
anticipate the ability of people with a
camera and a microphone and an internet
connection to out Fox massive
institutions and people with Superior
access to information
so what I think happened during coid was
Goliath literally didn't know what a
podcast was and he certainly couldn't
figure out
why whatever happens in Joe Rogan's man
cave should matter to anyone right
Goliath knew that he owned all of the
major media properties that sufficient
to control the public mind and what Joe
Rogan says and what Joe Rogan's guests
say doesn't make a goddamn bit of
difference Goliath was sure of that and
he was wrong so the reason that they
have revealed themselves is that we are
figuring out how to talk in spite of the
controls that they wish to apply they
try to get in a sandbox and we've
figured out a way to speak that isn't
you know we've figured out how to Tunnel
out of the sandbox so that's a battle
I'm not saying we won we didn't no
but right path yeah and and that's
that's the that's the thing that I love
the most
about human species that we in times of
trouble and when we're being pushed to
the corner our creativity comes out we
find another way just like water and
this is what has happened here we've
been pushed to the corner we found
another way and again like you said we
didn't win yet but you know there there
are different paths that are opening up
thanks to that limitation that has been
forced on us and it will continue to
happen as this escalates and I'm I'm
looking forward to see what Humanity
unravels we we can be unpredictable and
we can be very creative and those are
two traits of the human species that uh
we sometimes
underestimate and so I love your your
story your
analogy Goliath in the end say what what
killed
Goliath uh a guy named elhanan as best
we understand it a guy named elhanan
killed him and I I think I think
slingshot was approximately right a rock
why why do we know that David did that
um you know this is narrative license
that basically because David goes on to
play the role that he does in the Bible
um it was sort of necessary to attribute
right that his origin s so you know it's
like when they take a really good book
and they composite two characters in
order to make it into a movie right they
streamline the story yeah nice
um yeah I will put one more piece on on
this puzzle there's something I've
noticed and I think uh this discussion
with you is the perfect place to deploy
it please there are a great many people
who I now I I didn't have a tremendous
number of Heroes before um before coid
but so many people I thought stood up so
bravely that they really do have that
status in my mind and I it doesn't it's
not it's not a superhuman thing it's
just somebody has shown terrific
strength of character and they now have
this status of of hero to me um the
heroes are
overwhelmingly at least in this era they
are overwhelmingly people who have a
healthy dose of what I would call Lone
Wolf ISM there's a part of them there's
a characteristic that human beings have
which is a vulnerability which is that
we are terribly afraid of being isolated
right and the reason for that is because
5,000 years ago if you were isolated by
your tribe because you believed in
compatible things that was the first
step to starvation so we we fear
isolation as if it was death because
frequently for our ancestors it
was so that means people are manipulable
and they will sign up for things that
they should know are nonsense because
fear drives them to do it and the
heroes have enough independence of mind
that it doesn't matter that everybody
else thinks something different they can
see the evidence in front of them and
they will talk about it come hell or
high water the problem is that the
people who have that wonderful
characteristic that necessary
characteristic are often terrible at
confederating they don't know how to
team up because they're lone wolves and
so one thing that I absolutely fear in
the aftermath of what happened on
October 7th in Israel is that it caused
a lot of people who were learning the
skill of Team teaming up a skill that
was
um made fundamentally important by the
shenanigans over
coid those people are suddenly eyeing
each other with suspicion because they
find themselves in different places on
this issue which they have almost
universally
oversimplified yeah so I I worry that
that was an innovation that Goliath is
learning things about how to deal with
us and one of the ways feed us something
that will cause us to not understand
each other anymore and it's time for us
to level up and learn um you know how
for example uh not to suddenly become
suspicious of Mike Ben just because uh
somebody decides to write a story about
him at a particularly important
moment
wow this is so true it's the
sophistication of divide and conquer I
see it inside of Israel and I see it
definitely in the larger Global
community that was formed after coid and
how people are taking sides so quickly
and getting upset with each other and
yes the fact that we are okay being on
our own and we don't need anyone we
we've already done it once or twice or a
few times in our lives now we can
go and live the rest of our lives like
that we forget the power of the
group and we must have each other we
must have each other in order to win
this and then it's going to be as you
can see what's happening in Israel and
it's going to happen in other places in
the world and I think it's going to
escalate in Israel not necessarily with
other countries around us but inside of
Israel I think we're going to have a
proper crisis of divide inside the
Israeli uh Society of are we for or
against pulling out of the settlements
this is going to be a future question
that we have to handle and it's going to
tear the it could tear the country apart
and we we must find the way to transcend
those issues and see the bigger picture
and the bigger Goliath as you're saying
if we don't see that and you know look
long term and Far Away into the future
then we're definitely going to lose that
game it's super important what you're
saying well I think uh you know may
maybe this is the place to leave it I
will just say that once upon a time
Goliath was a
person right he was a brutal terrible
person and he was taken down by another
person elh Hanan who we composite into
David in the present Goliath has scaled
way up it's not a
person it's something much
bigger David has to scale up too we are
effectively David and in order to play
our proper role we have to learn how to
function coherently and not leap to
suspicions about each other
that will make it
impossible to take Goliath out because
we have to take Goliath out we do
because um frankly I think we have two
choices for history we can either return
to lineage against lineage competition
or we can all step into the Cosmopolitan
future and we can retain our Traditions
but we can stop suspecting each other
and prioritizing each other based on our
genes which is something if you
understand how ridiculous it is to let
your genes decide who you should like
then you know it would be Preposterous
to allow lineage to dominate our world
we
simply Israel has to take the one foot
that it's got in the west and it needs
to put the other foot in the west the
Middle East needs to come along and
really the whole world because as long
as there are large pock ETS of people
who see our genetic lineages as the
dominant most important factor they are
in a position to cancel the well-being
that the rest of us would seek because
it is simply
better amen to that
Brett amen all right well ifrat this has
been a
um I don't even know what the word is
it's been a very important conversation
uh from my perspective I hope so I was
actually pretty nervous before and I it
was fascinating for me where we took
this I'm being grounded back to the
reality in Israel you know going back to
what's happening here but at the same
time I feel encouraged and hopeful that
it's still possible to make my voice
heard and to have a stage like this with
you and with other
people I think it's um if this is not
inspirational to someone out there then
I don't know what this conversation for
yeah agreed um well it's been a pleasure
and I um look forward to hearing your
observations as events progress people
where can they find you on Twitter uh a
flat fixon or
Telegram and
substack and yeah so let us spell out
your Twitter handle that's the place
people are going to have the easiest
time finding the rest of your links oh
it's going to be on the screen oh okay
yeah we're gonna put it on okay good all
right wonderful well a frat um thank you
so much for doing this and uh good luck
um yeah we needed actually as we were
saying goodbye I'm hearing booms outside
oh my goodness yeah rocket going off
again time to today please please please
stay safe thank you thanks for this
Brit all right thanks for joining us
everyone